and I never made it past the random
number generator filter so the the only
way Gordon was volunteering to do this
yeah yeah so tikka DM Tucker them or
take care of the must the other have
they own and pronounce it it's one of
the world's most popular Python packages
six million downloads last month I think
half a million people have read the
documentation it's hard coded into
anaconda because Conda hasn't heard of
get sub modules anyway um yeah so what
is it it's just a it's a progress meter
so if you go to any of these landing
pages the first thing you'll probably
notice cuz I candy
it's a gif I'll go through all the
features shown here plus hopefully a few
which you haven't heard of before for
those of you don't know this library
let's say you take a simple for loop in
Python and you're wondering when will it
end so with the simple 4 characters of
code T qdm you can wrap any in trouble
and you get this nice progress bar for
free it's wonderful cuz it works in the
terminal Windows Linux Mac Jupiter known
books basically everywhere we also
provide this T range convenience
function so that's down to one extra
character of code now to get an extra
progress bar it supports the same
options as T gdm itself so you can add a
custom description a bunch of other bar
format arguments as well I'll go through
some other optional arguments later and
of course you can use this outside your
Python modules on the command line
itself so if you use T key them to you
know measure the throughput of a pipe in
terms of number of lines per second or
bikes per second if you specify total
you get a full progress bar as well and
so why use this obviously it's
incredibly easy to use we pay attention
to overhead as well worst case scenario
even if you have an empty for loop we're
all it's doing is displaying a progress
bar it's don't man o seconds we have
intelligent estimated time remaining
unlike windows file copy 2 hours 3 days
infinity we don't do that works works in
anything which is you know equally
broken cross-platform but hey Jupiter
notebooks as I mentioned and it has no
dependencies than any other Python
modules so quick recap of usage you can
wrap any insurable character arrays
numpy arrays whatever pandas it just
works you don't have to wrap it within a
for loop you can create a tiki name
object outside and then called member
athis is just set description and things
like that you don't even need an
iterable at all you can just create two
object with the total and call update as
in when you feel like it and if you do
this try and treat the progress bar a
bit like a file object so use the with
syntax or use the close syntax it's just
good programming practice if you're
using it as a module I'd recommend you
use the Python 3 version simply because
python 3 is a little more efficient when
it comes to dealing with standard input
and output but feel free to use just a
Python 2 version if you want to so for
example say you're printing out all the
lines of code in your Python files in
Linux this is the command is the TDM
version some fancy bar forms on seeing
arguments here as well say you're
backing up a directory take your damn
version again specifying a total so you
get a nice progress bar 7-zip
equivalents in case you're interested in
terms of documentation import TQM run
help if you're in a notebook take a damn
question mark and on the command line
help of course you've got more options
than you can shake a keyboard at so
there's also the examples folder online
the wiki there's this Jupiter notebook
itself you don't have to install Jupiter
or anything you can just run it within
your browser click those two buttons and
here's the interesting bit of the talk
so for those of you actually use this
before so we have member functions which
you might find useful set description
set post fix is particularly nice
because it takes any arbitrary list of
arguments and tries it's best to pretty
format them so pretty useful for machine
learning that sort of thing we also have
things like the bar format to completely
customize exactly what your bar looks
like really abusing Python formatting
notation to use this postfix thing in
order to you know access nested
dictionaries and things like that and we
support that's the progress bars as well
so you can have multiple bars displaying
on top of each other if you're using
this on the command line on Windows you
might have to install colorama as a
dependency to make it less broken we we
also allow you to specify a position
just in case you're doing multi-threaded
stuff in order to get the bars
displaying correctly on top of each
other than the right order if you're
trying to use this with you in external
libraries you can use callbacks so for
example say you're downloading with
something with URL Lib here's the Tiki
dam version most of this is just a
simple wrapper so
Tiki dam has this update which expects
Delta iteration so number of iterations
elapsed since you lost called its update
and URL Lib once an update - which is
the total number of iterations called so
far so that's just four lines
the code giving it to this report hook
as URL live calls it again we're being
fancy hero yet specifying units as bytes
and unit scaling that sort of thing and
you got this nice progress you can
specify total and that would be a
progress bar yeah if you're doing some
machine learning say it Terrace model
and you did model outfit this is the
annoying sort of output you might get
and and then again with three or four
lines code you can you can give this
little wrapper and get this nice tedium
progress bar we have pandas wrappers as
a mansion so you can do a series map
apply goop by progress apply that sort
of thing and of course we have no quick
integration so you can import TN range
and for a notebook or tkm notebook mix
and maximum wrap them up have nested
progress bars it just works here's a gif
of what that sort of looks like nice
attention to detail it'll turn red if
you break out of a progress bar halfway
through or turn green when it's
completed and if you're not sure whether
your end users are using a Jupiter
notebook or going to be running that
code in the command line you can always
import from TQM Auto which will
automatically figure out what your front
end is and I'd like to finish with this
quick graphic tweet which went viral
about a year ago I think highlighting
how few people are responsible for
maintaining some of the world's most you
know popular numerical paths and
packages and here's the Technium version
as well just reaching out so sure
[Applause]